ce matin à gré les affichettes des
journaux semblait marquer à chaque coin
de rue le temps écoulé depuis le drame
un mois dans kate est toujours pas
d'interpellation d'explications sur le
meurtre d'alexia seuls les avocats
désormais aux livres et quelques
éléments selon eux la justice avance
répond silence mais à grand pas on a
retrouvé des indices en nombre important
ces indices en nombre importants vont
permettre d investigation elle-même
importantes et notamment des
investigations techniques scientifiques
et notamment des prélèvements adn
on sait des choses sur les différents
intervenants de façon directe ou
indirecte
c'est pas que mon sentiment c'est que
effectivement on sent que l'anc est
arrivé à son terme et que l'échéance se
serait plutôt d'ici la fin décembre
en tout cas un petit peu avant les fêtes
selon cet avocat le crime aurait été
commis dans l'improvisation d'où les
nombreux indices mais alors pourquoi
attardé si les pistes semblent aussi
claire là encore l'avocat explique
l'embargo imposé par la justice
je pense que la section de recherches
qui fait un travail en profondeur ne
veut pas se tromper c'est mon sentiment
qu'ils veulent une interpellation et pas
2 équivalent interpellé la bonne
personne reste les rumeurs assez
présentes à gré concernant le mari de la
joggeuse
le jour du drame son employeur l'a
croisé il a vu un jeune homme sans souci
voilà c'est pas un élément anodin si
vous voulez pour moi qui connais
notamment l'heure approximative du décès
d'alexia ça conforte simplement mon
sentiment que ce garçon est une victime
dans ce dossier que idole la victime de
la mort de son épouse
les parents d'alexia d'aval ont rouvert
leurs commerces longtemps ceinturé par
des milliers de fleurs dans le centre de
gray ils sont nombreux à souhaiter la
fin de cette interminable attente et
trouver une réponse à ces deux questions
qui et pourquoi